the las vegas convention center opens
today as a mass vaccination site but
it's only for the second dose
bianca holman is there live now with
what to expect once you're inside good
morning bianca
hey good morning alex on monday we got a
behind the scenes look
as nurses got their second dose of the
kobit 19 shot and
we spoke with a few of them and they say
they were relieved and satisfied
with the process so here's a look inside
the convention center now
the first and second doses are given at
different locations so at the convention
center it's the second dose
only you must have your cdc immunization
card when you arrive
the staff they'll check you in to make
sure that the interval dates are correct
after you're checked in you head over to
the blue side from moderna shot or the
red
for the pfizer shot then you're observed
for 15 to 30 minutes
in a waiting area i thought everything
was great the different colors to keep
people separate make sure you're getting
the right vaccine
the nurses were great if i had any
questions they would have helped
me out and it was just really easy
so the site is going to be open tuesday
through saturday
8 30 to 3 30 8 30 a.m to 3 30 in the
afternoon
of course the health district says again
be patient this is a process that is
evolving
but again remember that the convention
center is only for those who received
their first dose through the health
district we've got all the information
on our website on how to make an
appointment
at 8newsnow.com reporting live from
paradise convention center drive bianca
holman
8 news now